s
comme langue première a même
atteint de nouveaux sommets.
- Le Québec, château fort de
la langue française en Amérique
du Nord, tient toujours, mais
partout dans
la province, le français recule.
77,5 % d77,5 % d77,5 % d77,5 % n
parle régulièrement
la langue à la maison.
Il y a 5ait 79 %.
Au même moment, plus
d'un mil
du Québec adoptent l'anglais
comme première lemière lemière e
officielle; un record.
ÉRIC CARON-MALENFANT Centre de
- Dans le cas de l'anglais
au Québec, il est fort possi
que ce soit lié, en fait,
à des facteurs, en grande partie
à des fe de résidents
non permanents qui se sont
établis au Québec, de façon
générale, de 2016 à 2021,
a été en augmentation.
Legault, en tout cas,
c'est une nouvelle occasion
de justifier sa loi
sur la langue française,
adoptée en mai dernier.
inquiétant, puis on a eu raison
d'agir avec le pro 96.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau,
lui aussi, se dit préoccupé
et espère que sa langues
officielles sera votée
dans les mois.
GINETTE PETITPAS TAYLOR, min.
fédérale des Langues officielles
- Nous sment à rment à rment à e
le français est en déclin dans
Et puis, c'est pour
cette raison que nous allons
de l'avant avec une loi qui
plan d'action.
- Mais les partisd'opposition lt
de faire partie du problème
et non de la solution.politiqueC
- Le gouvernement doitavoir plu.
la loi doit avoir plus de
mordant pour faire respecter...
MARIO BEAULIEU, p.-p. du BQ en
matière de langues officielles
- Son projet de loi ne renforce
pas le français. Il vient
empêcher le gouvernement
la loi 101 aux entreprises
de compétence fédérale. Tous
les indicateurs sont au rouge.
(cris de joie)
- À l'extérieurt
au rouge. Au Nouveau-Brunswick,
seule province bil
la proportion de ceux qui ont
le français comme première
langue p cinq ans. cinq ans. ci.
En Ontario : de 3,8 à 3,4 %.
Au Manit,1 à 2,7 %.
- Dans toutes nos communautés...
- Pour la Fédération
ennes, la ennes, la ennes, la en
est claire : il faut attirer
mmigrants qui parlent
- Pour la Fédération
des communautés francophones
et acadiennes, la solution
est claire : il faut attirer
plus d'immigrants qui parlen
LIANE ROY, Féd. des communautés
francophones et acadienne
- Si on avait respecté
les cibles en immigration
francophone au Can
on aurait eu des gains.
- Les données du r
sont sans appel et mettent
donc plus de pression sur
le gouvernement Trn
de la Loi sur les langues
officiels vite.
Mais même avec ce projet de loi,
plusieurs doutent que ce sera
ais au pays.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Ott